Sometimes it feels like the universe is just
messing with you. I have up on screen here a
sequence of computations and don't worry, in
a moment we're going to unpack and visualize
what each one is really saying. What I
want you to notice is how the sequence
follows a very predictable, if random seeming
pattern, and how each computation happens to
equal pi. And if you are just messing around
evaluating these on a computer for some reason,
you might think that this was a pattern that would
go on forever. But it doesn't. At some point,
it stops and instead of equaling pi, you get a
value which is just barely, barely less than pi.
Alright, let's dig into what's going on here. The
main character in the story today is the function
sin of X divided by X. This actually comes
up commonly enough in math and engineering
that it gets its own name, "sinc" and the way
you might think about it is by starting with
a normal oscillating sin curve and then
sort of squishing it down as you get far
away from zero by multiplying it by 1 over
X and the astute among you might ask about
what happens at X equals 0 since when you plug
that in, it looks like dividing zero by zero
and then the even more astute among you may
fresh out of a calculus class could point out
that for values closer and closer to zero,
the function gets closer and closer to one.
So, if we simply redefine the sinc function at
0 to equal 1, you get a nice continuous curve.
All of that is a little by the by because
the thing we actually care about is the
integral of this curve from negative infinity
to infinity. Which you think of as meaning the
area between the curve and the X axis, or
more precisely the signed area. Meaning you
add all the area bound by the positive
parts of the graph in the X axis and
you subtract all of the parts found by the
negative parts of the graph and the X axis.
Like we saw at the start, it happens to be
the case that this evaluates to be exactly pi,
which is nice and also a little weird
and it's not entirely clear how you
would approach this with the usual tools
of calculus. Towards the end of the video,
I'll share the trick for how you would do this.
Progressing on with the sequence I opened
with, the next step is to take a copy of the
sinc function where you plug in X/3, which
will basically look like the same graph but
stretched out horizontal by a factor of three.
When we multiply these two functions together,
we get a much more complicated wave whose
mass seems to be more concentrated towards
the middle and with any usual functions, you
would expect this completely changes the area.
You can't just randomly modify an integral
like this and expect nothing to change.
So already, it's a little bit weird that
this result also equals pi, that nothing has
changed. That's another mystery you should
add to your list. And the next step in the
sequence was to take an even more stretched out
version of this sinc function by a factor of 5,
multiply that by what we already have and again,
look at the signed area underneath the whole curve,
which again equals pi. And it continues
on like this; with each iteration,
we stretch out by a new odd number
and multiply that into what we have.
One thing you might notice is how except
that the input X equals 0, every single
part of this function is progressively getting
multiplied by something that's smaller than one.
So you would expect as the sequence progresses
for things to get squished down more and more
and if anything, you would expect the
area to be getting smaller. Eventually,
that is exactly what happens but what's bizarre is
that it stays so stable for so long and of course,
more pertinently, that when it does break at the
value 15 it does so by the tiniest tiny amount.
And before you go thinking this is the
result of some numerical error, maybe
because we're doing something with floating point
arithmetic, if you work this out more precisely,
here is the exact value of that last integral,
which is a certain fraction of pi where the
numerator and the denominator are absurd.
They're both around 400 billion billion billion.
So, this pattern was described
in a paper by a father-son pair;
Jonathan and David Borwein, which is
very fun, and they mentioned how when
a fellow researcher was computing these
integrals using a computer algebra system,
he assumed that this had to be some kind of bug,
but it's not a bug. It is a real phenomenon.
And it gets weirder than that actually - if
we take all these integrals and include yet
another factor 2cos(x) which again, you would
think changes their values entirely - you can't
just randomly multiply new things into an
this, it continues to equal pi for much
much longer and it's not until you get to the
number 113 that it breaks. And when it breaks,
it's by the most puny absolutely
subtle amount that you could imagine.
So, the natural question is - what on
earth is going on here? And luckily
there actually is a really satisfying
explanation for all this. The way I
think I'll go about this is to show you
a phenomenon that first looks completely
unrelated but it shows a similar pattern
where you have a value that stays really
stable until you get to number 15 and
then it falters by just a tiny amount.
And then after that, I'll show
why this seemingly unrelated
phenomenon is secretly the same as all our
integral expressions but in disguise. So,
turning our attention to what seems completely
different - consider a function that I'm going
to be calling rect(x) which is defined
to equal 1 if the input is between -1/2
and 1/2 and otherwise it's equal to 0. So,
the function is this boring step basically.
This will be the first in a sequence of function
that we define, so I'll call it f1(x) and each
new function in our sequence is going to be a
kind of moving average of the previous function.
So, for example, the way the second iteration will
be defined is to take this sliding window whose
width is 1/3 and for a particular input X, when
the window is centred at that input X, the value
in my new function drawn below is defined to be
equal to the average value of the first function
above inside that window. So, for example when
the window is far enough to the left, every value
inside it is zero, so the graph on the bottom is
showing zero. As soon as that window starts to go
over the plateau a little bit, the average value
is a little more than zero and you see that in the
graph below. And notice that when exactly half
the window is over that plateau at one and half
of it is at zero, the corresponding value in the
bottom graph is one half and you get the point.
The important thing I want you to focus on is how
when that window is entirely in the plateau above
where all the values are one, then the average
value is also one, so we get this plateau on
our function at the bottom. Let's call this
bottom function f2(x) and what I want you to
think about is the length of the plateau for
that second function. How wide should it be?
If you think about it for a moment, the distance
between the left edge of the top plateau and the
left edge of the bottom plateau will be exactly
half of the width of the window. So, half of
one third and similarly on the right side, the
distance between the edges of the plateaus is half
of the window width. So, overall, it's one minus
that window width, which is one minus a third.
The value we're going to be computing,
the thing that will look stable for a
while before it breaks is the value of this
function at the input zero, which in both of
these iterations is equal to one because it's
inside that plateau. For the next iteration,
we're going to take a moving average of that
last function but this time with the window
whose width is one fifth. It's kind of fun to
think about why as you slide around this window,
you get a smooth out version of the previous
function and again, the significant thing
I want you to focus on is how when that
window is entirely inside the plateau of
the previous function, then, by definition,
the bottom function is going to equal one.
This time, the length of that plateau on the
bottom will be the length of the previous one,
1-1/3 minus the window width, 1/5th. The
reasoning is the same as before - in order
to go from the point where the middle of
the window is on that top plateau to where
the entirety of the window is inside
that plateau is half the window width
and likewise on the right side and once
more, the value to record is the output
of this function when the input is
zero. Which again, is exactly one.
The next iteration is a moving average with the
window width of 1/7th - the plateau gets smaller
by that 1/7. Doing one more iteration with 1/9,
the plateau gets smaller by amount. And as we
keep going, the plateau gets thinner and thinner
and also notice how just outside of the plateau,
the function is really really close to one because
it's always been the result of an average between
the plateau at one and the neighbours, which
themselves are really really close to one.
The point at which all of this breaks
is once we get to the iteration where
we're sliding a window with width
1/15th across the whole thing.
At that point, the previous plateau is
actually thinner than the window itself. So,
even at the input X=0, this moving average have
to be ever so slightly smaller than one. And the
only thing that's special about the number 15 here
is that as we keep adding the reciprocals of these
odd fractions - 1/3 plus 1/5th plus 1/7th,
on and on, it's once we get to 1/15th that
that sum grows to be bigger than one and in the
context of our shrinking plateaus, having started
with a plateau of width one, it's now shrunk
down so much that it will disappear entirely.
The point is, with this as a sequence of functions
that we've defined by seemingly random procedure,
if I ask you to compute the values of
all of these functions at the input zero,
you get a pattern which initially looks stable,
it's one, one, one, one, one, one, one but by
the time we get to the eighth iteration, it
falls short ever so slightly, just barely.
This is analogous, and I claim more than just
analogous to the integrals we saw earlier,
where you have a stable value at pi, pi, pi,
pi, pi until it falls short just barely. And
as it happens, this constant from our moving
average process that's ever so slightly smaller
than one is exactly the factor that sits in
front of pi in our series of integrals. So,
the two situations aren't just qualitatively
similar, they're quantitatively the same as well.
And when it comes to the case where we add
the 2 cosine of X term inside the integral,
which cause the pattern to last a lot
longer before it broke down, in the analogy,
what that will correspond to is the same
setup but where the function we start with
has an even longer plateau - stretching from
x = -1 up to 1, meaning its length is 2. So,
as you do this repeated moving average process,
eating into it with smaller and smaller windows,
it takes a lot longer for them to eat into the
whole plateau. More specifically, the relevant
computation is to ask - how long do you have to
add these reciprocals of odd numbers until that
sum becomes bigger than two? And it turns out that
you have to go until you hit the number 113. Which
will correspond to the fact that the integral
pattern there continues until you hit 113.
And by the way, I should emphasize that there
is nothing special about these reciprocals of
odd numbers; one third, one fifth, one seventh
- that just Happens to be the sequence of values
highlighted by the Borweins in their paper
that made the sequence mildly famous in nerd
circles. More generally, we could be inserting
any sequence of positive numbers into those sinc
functions and as long as the sum of those numbers
is less than one, our expression will equal pi,
but as soon as they become bigger than one, our
expression drops a little below pi and if you
believe me that there's an analogy with these
moving averages, you can hopefully see why.
But of course, the burning question is why
on earth should these two situations have
anything to do with each other? From here,
the argument does bring in two mildly heavy
bits of machinery. Namely Fourier Transforms
and convolutions. And the way I'd like to go
about this is to spend the remainder of this
video giving you a high level sense of how
the argument will go without necessarily
assuming you're familiar with either of
those two topics and then to explain why the
details are true in a video that's dedicated
to convolutions. In particular something
called The Convolution Theorem since it's
incredibly beautiful and it's useful well
beyond this specific very esoteric question.
To start, instead of focusing on this function
sin(x)/x, where we want to show why the signed
area underneath its curve is equal to pi,
we'll make a simple substitution where we
replace the input X with π*x, which has the
effect of squishing the graph horizontally
by a factor of pi and so, the area
gets scaled down by a factor of pi,
meaning our new goal is to show why this
integral on the right is equal to exactly one.
By the way, in some engineering context, people
use the name "sinc" to refer to this function with
the pi on the inside since it's often very nice
to have a normalized function, meaning the area
under it is equal to one. The point is, showing
this integral on the right is exactly the same
thing as showing the integral on the left, it's
just a change of variables. And likewise for all
of the other ones in our sequence, go through each
of them, replace the X with the π*x and from here,
the claim is that all these integrals are not
just analogous to the moving average examples
but that both of these are two distinct ways
of computing exactly the same thing. And the
connection comes down to the fact that this sinc
function or the engineer sinc function with the pi
on the inside is related to the rect function
using what's known as a Fourier Transform.
Now if you've never heard of a Fourier Transform,
there are a few other videos on this channel all
about it. The way it's often described is
that if you want to break down a function
as the sum of a bunch of pure frequencies
or in the case of an infinite function,
a continuous integral of a bunch of pure
frequencies, the Fourier Transform will
tell you all the strength and phases for
all those constituent parts. But all you
really need to know here is that is something
which takes in one function and spits out a
new function and you often think of it as
kind of rephrasing the information of your
original function in a different language. Like
you're looking at it from a new perspective.
For example, like I said, this sinc function
written in this new language where you take a
Fourier Transform looks like our top hat rect
function. And vice versa by the way. This is a
nice thing about Fourier Transforms for functions
that are symmetric about the Y axis, that is
its own inverse, and actually the slightly more
general fact that we'll need to show is how when
you transform the stretched out version of our
sinc function where you stretch it horizontally
by a factor of K, what you get is a stretched
and squished version of this rect function.
But of course, all of these are just meaningless
words and terminology unless you can actually do
something upon making this translation. And
the real idea behind why Fourier Transforms
are such a useful thing for math is that
when you take statements and questions
about a particular function and then you look
at what they correspond to with respect to the
transformed version of that function, those
statements and questions often look very very
different in this new language, and sometimes
it makes the questions a lot easier to answer.
For example, one very nice little fact,
another thing on our list of things to show,
is that if you want to compute the integral of
some function from negative infinity to infinity,
this signed area under the entirety of
its curve, it's the same thing as simply
evaluating the Fourier Transformed version
of that function at the input zero. This is
a fact that will actually just pop right out
of the definition and representative of a more
general vibe that every individual output of
the Fourier Transform function on the right
corresponds to some kind of global information
about the original function on the left.
In our specific case, it means if you
believe me that this sinc function and
the rect function are related with
the Fourier Transform like this,
it explains the integral which is otherwise
a very tricky thing to compute because it's
saying all that signed area is the same thing
as evaluating rect at zero which is just one.
Now, you could complain - surely this just moves
the bump under the rug. Surely computing this
Fourier Transform, whatever that looks like
would be as hard as computing the original
integral. But the idea is that there's lots
of tips and tricks for computing these Fourier
Transforms and moreover that when you do,
it tells you a lot more information than
just that integral. You get a lot of bang
for your buck out of doing the computation.
Now, the other key fact that will explain
the connection we're hunting for is that if
you have two different functions and you
take their product and then you take the
Fourier Transform of that product, it would be
the same thing as if you individually took the
Fourier Transforms of your original function
and then combined them using a new kind of
operation that we'll talk all about in
the next video known as a Convolution.
Now, even though there's a lot to be explained
with convolutions, the upshot will be that in our
specific case with these rectangular functions,
taking a convolution looks just like one of the
moving averages that we've been talking about
this whole time. Combined with our previous
fact that integrating in one context looks
like evaluating at zero in another context,
if you believe me, that multiplying in one
context corresponds to this new operation,
convolutions, which for our example you
should just think of as moving averages,
that will explain why multiplying more and
more of these sinc functions together can
be thought about in terms of these progressive
moving averages and always evaluating at zero,
which in turn gives a really lovely intuition for
why you would expect such a stable value before
eventually something breaks down as the edges of
the plateau inch closer and closer to the center.
This last key fact by the way has a special name,
it's called the Convolution Theorem and again,
it's something that we'll
go into much more deeply.
I recognize that it's maybe a little unsatisfying
to end things here by laying down three magical
facts and saying "everything follows from
those", but hopefully this gives you a
little glimpse of why powerful tools like Fourier
Transforms can be so useful for tricky problems.
It's a systematic way to provide a shift
in perspective where hard problems can
sometimes look easier. If nothing else, it
hopefully provides some motivation to learn
about these beautiful things
like the convolution theorem.
As one more tiny teaser, another fun
consequence of this convolution theorem
will be that it opens the doors for an algorithm
that lets you compute the product of two large
numbers very quickly - like way faster
than you think should be even possible.
So with that, I'll see you in the next video.